Vsauce today I've got more creativity
for you but not the kind you have to buy
or wait for these are 10 things you can
do online now guys
dawn sign minister 9 recommended a great
game where you have to jump to avoid
holes in the floor of course jumping
onto the walls makes them the new floor
a similarly cool perspective element is
found in sky island recommended by lil
Sputnik it begins as a classic 2d game
but then it gets difficult so you have
to use your mouse to click and drag the
reveal hidden dimensions and solve the
puzzles in ways that would be impossible
without three dimensions now let's get
some action gun blood is a game based on
the classic Western shootout you have to
hover your mouse over the barrel and
wait for the countdown then draw it's
kind of scary one of the most famous
games is powder game you can arrange
materials like a c4 box filled with
nitroglycerin with a fuse now many of
you have probably played it already
but if you'd like to play with gravity
instead of pressure try Aeon I found it
pretty difficult but basically all you
have to do is arrange gravity wells to
suck gas out of gas giants and pull it
into rings stabilize the exchange and
you win another game so famous I'm
afraid to mention it is line Rider now
you draw a line and then press play and
send a guy sliding down it but here is a
fun twist solid skier is a fast-paced
real time line Rider click anywhere and
bam you're drawing a skiers slope guide
him to checkpoints and give him little
quick hills to launch him into the air
if you prefer problem solving and
riddles you might like not pron this
game calls itself the hardest riddle
available on the Internet and with the
possible exception of Tim tank's test
it's probably right you'll have to super
think outside the box for this one each
puzzle is a picture with different types
of clues in a hidden solution for
instance look up here it says
look in the dark
hmm let's get cuter with little wheel
it's pretty much a point and click game
but the animation is beautiful and your
cute little robot guy has to get the
power back so his friends can function
finally a website suggested by kinda
semi-pro your world of text comm it's
like the cursor site I showed you last
week except with text you can see people
writing stuff and add your own in real
time you can even add a slash and a word
to create your own private world of text
for instance to find out what is missing
from this video go to your world of text
calm the slash Vsauce
now someone may have changed it or
deleted it by the time you get there but
hey that's the magic of the Internet
and as always subscribe to Vsauce for
more and tell your friends to subscribe